empty nesters now have been for a while
how is that come on oh this is Douglas
and Lucy
hi
hello
um you have a new doggy I have a
puppy dot that's dot I forgotten how
much work a puppy is but she's so worth
it she's adorable and she's um very
funny and she's wicked smart so this is
your life now you you went into making
this beautiful line Henry Rose in fact I
was pouring it all over myself um all
weekend long I have a little video clip
this is my favorite Jake's house a lot I
know it really smells like like I'm
outdoors I mean you can pour it on as
I'm doing you just
did Jake's house I think that's my
favorite
oh
fog that's one I like yes of course it
is the stuff I like to eat it's
[Laughter]
Goron oh that smells so
good
hello I tested every single one and and
I read the pamplet about all the notes
but I love the names that you've chosen
for these like I I heard is Jake's house
is Jake your grandfather yes um it
smells like fresh cut grass it's the
most fresh beautiful there's also men in
it and menace menace is and fog and fog
window windows down windows down these
are such good names dark as night this
is also part of a slumber party set did
you have slumber parties when you were
younger I I we we were we were big into
slumber parties when I was young and um
and it was always just oh you just
wanted to create a little trouble you
know and it was always uh what did you
do to create trouble I mean it was like
kid trouble you know it was just like
you wouldn't go to sleep and then it was
like oh let's stay up all night I love
slumber party so much why did you decide
to call it the slumber party set well
when we um did the play date which was
um two two layering combinations
together um you know people really love
to layer and they love to play and so we
then when we did um we decided to do a
um a set of 12 of every single fragrance
in our little mini 10 MLS they're like
little mini M of these bottles yeah
those are the ones I was spraying
everywhere and um um I was looking I was
like what are we going to call this I
thought well gosh if these are the pl
dat this has to be the slumber party but
it also makes a really great um gift
um look at how beautiful this is I mean
come on look at
that you know what else happens at
slumber parties when you get a little
older is spin the bottle oh at slumber
parties I'm no you're
right no the that's not it well those
are more like recck room parties if the
boys sneak in yes that's true yeah
[Music]